was mitgebracht haben was dich
aufregenden das ist ein werbespot zum
thema klimaschutz im es gibt ein video
von paris for future das ist wie freude
ist future quasi ich wenig sagen als
weiblicher uns alle mit einbeziehen nur
in eltern und die man sich für umwelt
und das klima stark und haben dazu jetzt
diesen werbeclip rausgebracht
monster ist doch nix ist
[Musik]
er wird das kind alleine gelassen mit
demonstriert wird sogar noch abgesperrt
natürlichen glückwunsch stapelfeldt wort
der jan eindeutig mit angst spielen alle
auf panik setzt geht nur um angst und
das sehen wir hier in diesem spot geht
es um das thema klima klimawandel
klimaschutz aber wir sehen das ja
überhaupt in der ganzen debatte freitags
for future hier ist es parents for
future eine ebenfalls eine
vorfeldorganisation der grünen und in
zusammenarbeit mit freude ist future es
gibt nur beim thema klimaschutz um angst
und aus dem wissen ja auch das thema
klimawandel aus dem thema klimawandel
ist dann die klimakrise geworden
mittlerweile reden die meisten in dem
milieu nur noch von klimakatastrophe
also das ist es wird hier über das thema
klimaschutz permanent mit dem wort angst
regiert eine die katastrophe die
komplett davor steht und das perfide an
der geschichte ist jetzt ja dass auch
suggeriert wird die kinder sind die
einzigen die den durchblick haben und
die eltern sind richtig böse und
versuchen überhaupt nicht sich dieses
themas anzunehmen also auch die kinder
da wieder mit reinzuziehen auch mit der
angst der kinder ganz generell ob jetzt
klimaschutz oder andere dinge wieder
politik zu machen das ist ein bild was
wir jetzt schon
öfters gesehen haben und das sind
methoden die es eigentlich beim thema
corona haben es ja auch gemerkt es geht
immer um das thema angst und angst mit
kindern und politik die sich im angst
modus befindet ist oft schlechte politik
man muss eigentlich eher darüber
nachdenken nach vorne zu schauen was
kann man eigentlich tun um probleme zu
lösen und nicht eigentlich immer nur mit
angst und katastrophe zurückgehen aber
das ist zurzeit das einzige was einfällt
und wenn wir auch über das thema
sprechen 1,5 grad ziehen und es wird ja
mit einem dogma
in dieser debatte agiert haut der ju ist
das entscheidende wort also wie könnt
ihr nur wie könnt ihr es wagners und
genau das kommt ja in diesem spot auch
wieder zum ausdruck how der ju wie
kannst du einfach das licht ausmachen
wie kannst du die tür einfach
abschließen wie kannst du mich allein
lassen du böser böser papa also ein spot
der völlig völlig geschmacklos richtig
heute früh auf politik chef jan schäfer
die politik die nicht auf schlagende
argumente gesetzt sondern vor allen
dingen auf angst mache es die kreativen
spot also aufmerksam wurden wir
zumindest drauf
[Musik]